so this movie marks the first onscreen
pairing of Robert DeNiro and John
Travolta and that's all this movie has
going for it killing season is directed
by Mark Steven Johnson the man who
brought us daredevil Ghost Rider and
When in Rome somehow he was given a
project starring John Travolta and
Robert De Niro now apparently the
screenplay for this movie was on what's
called a blacklist and what that means
if you don't know is that it's a
screenplay that's on a list a very
well-regarded screenplays that haven't
been produced yet and now it has been
made so we get to see it this movies
about Robert De Niro he's a war veteran
he lives in a cabin in the middle of
nowhere he is very estranged from his
family he doesn't want to have anything
to do with really anyone he's pretty
much a broken man because of what
happened to him in the war John Travolta
plays a Serbian let me just let that
sink in John Travolta plays a Serbian
with the greatest beard ever and very
shiny hair very beautiful shiny hair
that's clearly actual hair and he has a
bit of a grudge against Robert De Niro
so he tracks him down in the woods and
somehow befriends him and gets him to
invite him into his cabin and then he
triggers a war between himself and
Robert De Niro and they face off against
each other in the woods now honestly one
of the coolest things about this movie
is the concept the idea of Robert De
Niro and John Travolta in the middle of
nowhere waging a one-man war against
each other that's pretty cool they have
to survive they have to use what they
can find they have to figure out ways to
defeat the other person without a lot of
technology or weaponry that is a great
concept this movie has no idea how good
of a concept it has this movie has no
idea the talent that the two stars in it
have because everything about this movie
is pretty much awful I mean this movie
really honestly is horrendous killing
season from the beginning is boring
bland and uninteresting for like the
first 30 minutes of the movie and once
things actually start happening where
you see these two guys start to fight
and you're like okay let's get it let's
get into it
it's just so poorly done it really is
the direction is so boring and
uninteresting and random shaky-cam shots
to mask the fact that these are two
stuntmen actually doing all the work
just really poorly made and I'm not even
talking about the screenplay
or the performances yet this screenplay
tries to take these characters in very
religious directions it tries to take
them in on pretentious / artsy meetings
that really don't have anything to do
with the fact that look this is a movie
about two guys fighting in the woods it
should be like predator and believe it
or not one of the early drafts of this
movie was going to be directed by John
McTiernan the guy who made predator that
did not happen unfortunately instead of
all of the awesome drama and suspense
that could be made from this movie we
get odd sequences where the men take
turns torturing each other in an overly
graphic ways that just feels like it's
completely unnecessary let's talk about
the historical aspect of this film
they just butcher anything that actually
happened with the war that they
continuously discuss and I'm not going
to say that it's like the biggest flaw
of this movie that's just really
annoying when they try to be so serious
and they change history because
inglorious basterds definitely change
history but that film understood what it
was doing and it was a very
tongue-in-cheek and funny
this film was tried to be super serious
and it keeps changing all the events of
history like it doesn't even matter it's
it's really dumb okay
let's talk a little bit about the
performances now we Robert De Niro in
this movie I'll give it to him he
doesn't really have anything to do okay
there's nothing really in this script or
in this film that gives him that meat
that he needs but honestly he must have
sat there and read the script I thought
I liked this let's do it and something
along the way change something messed up
something or he just honestly did not
care when he got this script because the
scenes that should be intense don't feel
intense because of the way the film's
directed the scenes that should be more
suspenseful don't feel that way at all
because of the construction of this
movie John Travolta however who I really
like is the most distracting villain
I've seen in years he's got the most
horrendous accent in this movie it's
laughable and that beard man oh my word
I mean this is Battlefield Earth
performance what the hell this movie
could have had so many things going for
it but it just squandered it all for
this really stupid boring overly
pretentious artsy and mainstream film in
the worst ways there's this horrendous
scene Robert De Niro is lying in a
Church okay and he just got really badly
injured he looks up at the cross and
through the wall the crack of the wall a
light beam shines down on him from the
Sun and the music is like I was just
sitting there like you've got to be
kidding me right now this is the Miss is
they believe that killing season had no
idea what it was doing everything about
this movie pretty much sucked I'm gonna
give killing season a d-minus simply
because of the fact that I was
interested in seeing how it turned out I
didn't want to stop watching the movie
because I at least wanted to see what
the outcome would be
I can't flat-out give it an F but this
movie sucks some royal royal crap it
really is bad so guys have you seen this
movie yet I don't recommend I don't see
it no but if you have what did you think
of the film as always guys if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]